mind your decisions i'm presh talwalkar
in rectangle abcd
side a b has a length equal to eight
we will then construct two circles in
the interior of the rectangle as shown
one circle is tangent to sides a b and b
c
the other circle is tangent to sides a d
and c d and the two circles are tangent
to each other
we will then construct e f that goes
through the tangent point between the
two circles
suppose e f is parallel to the side a b
and e f is equal to six
the question is what is the length bc
equal to
i think taka who's on twitter at pan btc
who created this puzzle
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we will prove the rather fascinating
result that bc is always equal to 9.
what's amazing is that bc is equal to 9
regardless of the sizes of the two
circles
because ef is equal to 6 that exactly
specifies that bc is equal to 9. why is
that the case
let's first review some concepts we'll
go over the perpendicular bisector of a
chord and the centers of tangent circles
first let's go over the perpendicular
bisector of a chord
suppose we have a circle with a chord a
b
let's construct the perpendicular
bisector l it'll be perpendicular and
it'll bisect a b
every single point on l will be
equidistant from a and b this will also
be true for the center of the circle
because the center of the circle has the
same distance to the points a and b
therefore the perpendicular bisector of
a chord passes through a circle center
now let's review the centers of tangent
circles
suppose we have circles a and b
that meet at a tangent point t
let's construct the tangent line
note that the radius a t will be
perpendicular to the tangent line as
will the radius bt
therefore atb will be a straight line
the centers and the tangent point are
collinear
this is true for both externally and
internally tangent circles
we'll use these facts to solve the
problem
we will first write t for the tangent
point between the two circles
we will then construct the perpendicular
bisector of e t
and that will contain the center of the
top circle
we will then construct the perpendicular
bisector of tf and that will contain the
center of the bottom circle
let's now calculate the vertical
distance between the two diameters of
these two circles
how can we do that
notice that e t plus t f is equal to e f
this means half of e t plus half of t f
is equal to half of e f
therefore we have the length of this
vertical distance will be equal to e f
over 2 which is equal to 3.
now let's consider the radius of the top
circle suppose it has a length equal to
x and then the radius of the bottom
circle which has a length equal to y
the vertical distance will be x
plus the distance between the two
centers plus y
we thus have this is equal to a b which
is equal to eight so we have x plus
three plus y is equal to eight
if we subtract three from both sides we
get that x plus y is equal to five
from here let's move this vertical
distance over to the left
this is exactly equal to three
we will then construct the line that
goes through the two centers of the two
circles and the tangent point
this will have a length equal to x plus
y
we just showed that x plus y is equal to
five
we thus have a right triangle with a
hypotenuse equal to five and one leg
equal to three we can use the gogo
theorem to determine the remaining leg
is equal to four and we have the famous
egyptian 3-4-5 right triangle
from here we'll construct the horizontal
distances
notice that we have a horizontal
distance of x here
we then have a horizontal distance of 4
between the two centers and finally we
have a horizontal distance of y
and this all together will be equal to
the length of bc
therefore bc is equal to x plus 4 plus y
since x plus y is equal to 5 we can
simplify that this is equal to 4 plus 5.
thus bc is equal to 9 exactly
and that's our answer
what's remarkable is that this is always
our answer because we have a 345 right
triangle that goes between the two
centers of the two circles
this exactly determines that bc will
always be equal to nine
i find it fascinating that this ancient
egyptian 345 right triangle is the key
to solving this problem incredible
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support